good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is another
beautiful day here in New York City it
is a Tuesday we are here hey Claude how
you durn hey guys happy Tuesday I hope
everyone's doing well as can be expected
um I am doing good I am tired
always always always tired I actually
had such a busy day in the queue
yesterday working on toast stuff and
then we recorded the red heads and the
red heads are just getting longer and
longer
um and again we recorded our audio
separately so that the audio is so
premium but it takes me five hours to
edit but it's so worth it because the
red heads are that premium so it was it
was a good day I turned and I watched
Great British baking show British baking
show I did I'm Nick vials podcast I like
he does this advice Eggman I mean it's
cool he actually like zooms in the
people who are asking for advice and
they were all toasters they like we're
expecting to see Nick and they were like
they thought they stumbled into the
wrong soom thing it was so funny and
they were really cute that's so funny
did you give out any good advice yeah
you know um I'm not really like a great
advice giver because I just think like
I'm always like saying you know your
problems could be worse you know which
is like not what people want to hear
when they're like seeking advice so I
was trying to be as helpful as possible
Nick is like so wise and so much like
older and more mature and like actually
was giving fabulous advice and I was
just like listening for the most part
but I think I did my part as co-host
yeah he gives really good advice he's
he's good at that
so do I feel like I get pretty good
advice I feel like sometimes under your
toasters I don't but I feel like as a
friend or a sister um and just like
someone in your life I give good advice
I think if you know me you you know that
I'm the person to come to yeah I feel
like our vibe on dear toasters is to
give kind of like the unpopular advice
like a little bit more tough love like
I've seen people write comments who say
like we're mean during your toasters but
it's like I always it's easy in a
situation that you're not included into
like play devil's advocate yes oh I love
playing devil's advocate mostly just
because I think perspective is so
important and that's something that we
talk a lot about on the redheads Book
Club episode which drops on Thursday
you still have so much time to read the
book because it took all of us like less
than six hours to read it's called in
five years and if your Seanie you're
gonna like it even there are a lot of
varying opinions it's really interesting
and then I announced my new book and
it's just a total departure from what
we've been reading and I think people
are gonna be shocked that's what a book
club is for differing opinions yes and
we really even though we're also similar
we have completely different opinions
about the books that we read so it's a
good one got me excited got me wearing
my Colgate sweatshirt today took this
down from the top of the closet um but
yeah that's that's all for me I think
McLean today my bathroom like could
really use a power scrub so I'm just
like so done like sweeping up my floors
like between the-- oh my hair everywhere
and Ben's chest hair like it's something
that really needs to be done every day
and it's back-breaking work and I just
like want to let it pile up but there's
no question like when I'll be able to
have my housekeeper come back it
probably won't be for a while so I just
the more I let it pile up the more work
I'm giving myself in a few days I'm just
I can't be bothered to clean right now
like listen yesterday I did not get out
of bed until 10:00 p.m. and I went into
the kitchen at 10:00 p.m. and there was
like dishes everywhere and I cleaned the
kitchen but like the kitchen is becoming
my least favorite place in the house
yeah it's it's tough honestly doing the
floors is not even that bad anymore
compared to some of the other things
like the bathroom it's my cross to bear
but it's also my happy place so you got
to keep her clean you got a keeper clean
well we the big show and once you start
like not keeping things clean that's
when it just all goes downhill like stay
above the cleanliness line yeah that's
like with personal hygiene and like
keeping your house clean if you're not
doing those two things during quarantine
which I've let myself go for like a week
both physically and in my apartment um
and it really makes an impact on your
mental health so as much as you don't
want to get up and wash your hair or
like your bathroom I think it's
important that we all keep doing it
there's no better feeling in the queue
than taking a shower and washing your
hair like it's just a reset like when
I'm laying in bed feeling like [ __ ] I'm
just like let me shower I'll be a whole
new woman if people don't know this
trick yet like try it it's a new
sensation just like getting in the
shower washing
hair maybe like pamper yourself a little
bit of a face mask of scrub get creative
it's a new feeling because normally like
during regular life I [ __ ] hate
showering it is my least favorite
activity I just it's always like I never
have time and it's just you have to do
so much but it's like now I have nothing
but time and would love something to do
so I actually agree that quarantine
activity of showering is super exciting
it's super super exciting got somewhere
to go
you've got like places to be people to
see very exciting okay well I feel like
it's time I feel like today's gonna be a
quickie no shows were on last night news
is decent news is decent yeah I just
wanted to wish you a happy Cinco de Mayo
thank you so much I'm actually really
craving now some Mexican food like I
really want to celebrate so maybe I'll
order something later I actually have a
home chef meal that's like a tortilla
soup so maybe I'll make that for lunch
and get best yeah I would love like a
taco bowl to go to my Oh such a fun day
for people but like it's actually the
worst day ever for us oh yes I was about
to say why we like Mexican food yes it
is very sad day for us because today's
our dad's birthday yeah and it's like I
just never feel like I want to do
anything today especially yeah well you
know what I actually feel like of all
the Memorial days that come with a loved
one passing the birthday is the happier
day because it's like a celebration if
we decided that you know if we weren't
in the queue and we wanted to hit the
town we could party like in his honor
that's true but you wouldn't do that on
like the anniversary of death no
honestly I find the most troublesome day
to be Father's Day because as an anagram
number one my biggest fear is like
missing out on activities and it's like
everyone's at the park at Stan they're
like with your dad and like I'm
literally at home you're not any grand
one you're any gram three very different
your anagram one I keep confusing that
yes I'm anagram one and I'm very funny
and you're a three in your Barry 3e and
you know that being said it's Mother's
Day this weekend so if you don't have a
mom or you don't have a relationship
with your mom just know like I stand
with you in solidarity because I feel
that on Father's Day and it's just like
not a good feeling and like I just can't
wait for the day to be over
usually yeah that is a tough one are you
always like think it's not gonna be and
then you're in it and it's just like
what about me yeah and if you have both
a mother and a father and you have a
fabulous relationship with them like
just don't take it for granted please
yes well anyways I hope everyone's
having a great Cinco de Mayo finding a
way to celebrate get festive have some
margaritas have some chips and guac oh
well have maybe I'll make some guac I
have some ripe avocados it's time it is
time for to eat avocados I'm just so who
would like in this place now where I
don't want to do anything because I
don't want to clean it up yeah but then
it's like I have time to clean it up
yeah and it's like you would think I'd
be so busy like watching shows but I've
really slowed down on RuPaul's Drag Race
I have found myself literally just
sitting in bed on my phone all day it's
crazy and it's so unhealthy yeah that's
that's really not good you need to find
the ovaries an excuse to put it down and
just [ __ ] read Jessica Simpson's book
for once and for all oh yes I will think
about it I'm also going to know that you
know I know that you won't but maybe if
I shame you enough publicly eventually
like you'll have to know I do want to
read it like I really do I mean I will
do I know that you do but I don't know
that you will um can I tell you
something funny that happened because
Ben went to the grocery store a few days
ago and I just like I wasn't in the mood
to like give him specifics and like cami
food you know yeah and he came back yeah
he came back with pop-tarts which i
thought was really interesting and I
opened one up yesterday I took it out of
the little tin foil and it had no
frosting on it like you know how it's
like the yeah beige and then there's
like white frosting with sprinkles on us
so we didn't have it I was like oh how
cool I got like a special like
manufacturers error like I thought I got
I could make my money suing pop-tarts
cuz I didn't get frosting then I opened
up the second one no frosting best
toaster oven
he bought unfrosted pop-tarts I didn't
even know that was made that is [ __ ]
sick sick and not in a good jeffree star
way yes ill like an illness
I still need in a cool way I still ate
it did you put your own like Jack
and [ __ ] on it no I'm so lazy like I
really just took the pop-tart back to my
bed and just like ate it
that's so funny I think I might make
another meatless bully me soon um I
gotta start getting rid of some of the
stuff in my freezer I'm in a space ya
know and it's like we've been
quarantined for so long now that like a
lot of the stuff that I thought would
last me a while it's like a while is up
it's very true I found garlic with like
this big mole of mold it was disgusting
like I just can't with produce anymore
like I don't know how I know garden does
it know like produce is sickening and
also does everyone just like know in
their heads the shelf life for most of
these items because for me it's just
like until I see mold yeah it's an
eyeball thing for sure nobody feel like
there's people that are like oh you know
avocados are this long and garlic is
this song and onions are this song and
I'm just like I have no idea I don't
know and I I have like a lot I have a
lot of things in my head like Real
Housewives like reality TV history like
just a lot that I have to like keep them
here at all times I can't be worried
about like the shelf life of produce
there's not enough space no there's not
enough space I'm small no I mean I have
a bag of carrots that obviously I've
never eaten there for Theo because
there's it's a good snack for him
unclear when we bought them and unclear
if I'm poisoning him
how is Theo other goodness carrot
poisoning okay if you're watching he is
just the cutest thing alive I don't know
why I'm whispering you're wearing air
pods but that's literally one of the
cutest things I've ever seen Claudia
that's beautiful it really is I miss him
so much that's probably like one of the
hardest parts yes not he talking to you
see like we used to like work together
every day you know hit the water cooler
in the beginning of quarantine I thought
that like Theo was loving having us home
so much now he seems so bored so done
with us like literally just goes into
his crate every day like a moody
teenager and I feel like honestly his
mental health is suffering I think so
too and I also feel like a lot of pet
owners are experiencing that with their
pets where it's like their pets are like
go back to work what do you do like this
this is my time time
person imagine going from having so much
alone time to no privacy at all yeah and
like when you train your dog however you
decide to train them you can train them
to be like more self-sufficient so a lot
of the things we did with Theo involving
the crate leaving him alone you don't
want them to be so dependent on you
because like if you have to go to work
they should be okay and I feel like I
did all that and it's for nothing now
because it's gonna be a reset when we go
back to work like the first time I have
to leave him alone he's gonna cry for
hours it's gonna make me so sad he comes
into the office head of culture for Tina
no but like sometimes I have like to
leave him alone then he'll come to the
auntie's okay I feel like I'm finally
wearing my ear pods right what do you
think 100% you want to know why I know
that cuz I didn't notice that usually I
see them like horizontally shoving out
of your ears and I didn't even notice em
titles like that yeah I'm getting better
honestly air pods like I have to charge
my ear pods every single day now because
I use them for so many activities in the
day like I use them for the toast I used
it for the redheads I use it for the
peloton and like they're gonna die I
used to like charge my earplugs whenever
I've never charged my ear pods in my
life and then one day it's gonna just
hit you we're gonna hear that ding in
your ear and you're gonna say what the
[ __ ] you know what happens it's like
you're on a plane on six hours of Game
of Thrones here and you know it's really
loud it [ __ ] scares me sometimes like
yeah oh I was like he's a plane okay the
first time it happened I didn't know
what it was until they completely died
and then like I had to use my brain to
figure out that they were dead they have
it's like not really clear no nothing's
clear unless you get it onto your phone
and they tell you what your person is oh
but to get the percent to pop up on your
phone is like a whole other journey oh
my god you're like flip flip flip flip
yeah and it's like if you get some Joe
Schmo sitting in row 50 like you had his
ear pods but you don't get yours totally
okay well speaking of Technology it's a
great segue into our first story so I
think without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and that's true jacks
but allow me a minute to let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by stamps calm for all of our sakes
we need to avoid crowds any way we can
right now but what if you need to go to
the post office what if you need postage
to send out letters and packages
don't worry stamps calm is here to help
anything you can do at the post office
you can do at stamps calm print postage
on demand skip those lines and crowds at
the post office plus you can actually
save money with discounts that you can't
get at the post office mmm
brings all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your computer in the
safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else you are
hunkering down right now whether you're
a small business sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
you're just working from home and need
to mail stuff stamps.com can handle it
all with ease quarantine or not I feel
like stamps calm is just so far superior
to the post office like if I can avoid
going to the post office like take my
money no like the past few the past year
has been like really taxing on me in the
stamps department before I found out
about stamps calm from like all the
stamps that I needed for my wedding
- all the stamps that I needed to send
out my thank-you cards it was just like
honestly really taxing and I'm so
grateful to stamps com that they exist
now you know and it's a real like factor
when you think of your budget you don't
think of like stamps but it's fully a
thing
poofy simply use any computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
to leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free package pick up or drop
it in a mailbox no human contact is
required it's that simple
and with stamps calm you get great
discounts - five cents offered off every
first-class stamp and stamp and up to
40% off usps shipping rates in addition
to offering discounted US Postal Service
rates stamps calm now also offers UPS
services with discounted rates up to 62%
plus with stamps calm you won't even
have to pay a UPS residential surcharge
their Sam calm is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe our listeners can
get a special offer that includes a
four-week free trial
sorry four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment so that's a four
week trial with free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in toast toas t that's
calm click the microphone at the top of
the home page and enter toast stay safe
my friends Thank You stamps.com
thank you Sam's calm okay our first
story is some very sweet beben news Elon
Musk and Grimes welcomed a beautiful
bebut very exciting the Tesla CEO posted
the first picture in response to a fans
comment that said we really need to see
a picture of the baby please do share
the photo featured a close-up of his
son's face with a tattoo filter on it
that had words like savage and moody
written on the baby's face the Elon
joked in a separate tweet quote never
too young for some ink haha then he
shared an actual photo of him looking
down at the baby at the hospital and
it's honestly so precious he also shared
that the couple named their child it's
spelled x AE a12 which prompted many to
speculate the proper way to pronounce
the name Elon liked a tweet that guests
the name to be X a sh arc angel and a
Wikipedia page screenshot showed that AE
is a ligature named ash the a12 is
thought to be in reference to the CIA
aircraft lockheed a-12 which was
codenamed archangel so if this is true
the baby's name is ash archangel so like
ash I love that name me - that sounds
like a normal name but when I saw it on
Twitter I was like Elon he's always like
pranking us you know he's like jokester
he's become like quite a meme stirrer
he's like the fat Jewish
ya know he really is um and I'm so happy
for them they're really cute um I feel
like they're they just like live in
their own world and it's nice it is nice
like there's truly a lid for every pot
and these two are emblematic of that um
also the name ash just reminded me of
our last redheads book club um book if
you know you know before we were
strangers I see dad do you think Elon
Musk is gonna be like strict well he's
already a dad to five sons from his
previous marriage lest we not forget so
I think but like I think in this next
face of a fatherhood for him you know
cuz I feel like his kids are a little
bit older than this is now um I think
it's gonna be different I feel like you
know he's probably working so hard back
in the day like he was a workaholic dad
building up Tesla
and now he's just like that creative dad
like hey bed do you want to go to Mars
yeah that's pretty sick for the baby
it's pretty sick for the better that bed
is gonna be full of creative energy
I feel like Elon Musk having um children
is like five children is one of the most
like underrated things in Hollywood you
know there's like so many things and so
there's so many things like that like
Ashton Kutcher has a twin like you know
weird things like that I think one must
having five kids that nobody knows or
talks out is one of those mysteries Elon
Musk is now a father of six it's just
not what I think of when I think of Elon
Musk I think Tesla I think Mars I think
you know he said he was gonna build a
train or something I don't know I think
of all these things Hyperloop yeah I
don't think a father but now I will yeah
daddy
honestly I [ __ ] love him we used to
talk about him all the time and I just
like I think he's so hilarious and smart
and Tesla's like doing really well I
think I mean I don't know I don't know
if it's just the david dobrik effect but
I'm like dying for a Tesla I'm sure you
know what when you say like david dobrik
Tesla I don't really like realize that
that's Elon Musk you know it's like
there's Elon Musk Tesla and and there's
like oh we're driving a Tesla yeah and
Elon Musk has been through you know
quite a few things in the last year you
know he's you know accused that hero of
being a pedophile but I feel like he's
in a good place now yeah like in the
place of having a newborn son with
Grimes you know grant is an interesting
girl she is but she's also a talented
girl you know she's very nice her music
I don't think I've ever heard it but I'm
sure there are a lot of people in
underground bars who do hear it all the
time no I like a few of her songs
they're there you would like them to
they're obviously you know edgy like her
but there have like a pop vibe yeah
she's very edgy she's very edgy um also
speaking of these two like they debuted
at the Met Gala was that last year um
everyone sharing photos from the Met
Gala on their instagrams and it's nice
yeah you know I'm once again not trying
to be negative I usually love the Met
Gala like it's just the pinnacle like
more of them
and it's the Kardashians are so
respected they're like it's just really
become an actual fun thing for me to
watch even though there's no red carpet
really like it's we don't get a lot we
just get photos there's a massive red
carpet well there's always red carpet no
there's no livestream like there's no
red carpet like there's no hope yes
there's no live show from the Met Gala
like they he does interviews
yeah like Brad Goreski stands on the
side of the stairs and like tries to
catch people like nobody really really
talks to press and if they do like it
gets clipped out after like you can't
turn on your TV and watch the Met Gala
red carpet interesting we watch it
unfold on social media which is like it
yes like my photos yeah usually I
wouldn't like that like I just want to
see but it just makes it so exciting and
like so mysterious and like so like I
can't touch it you know it's like not
there yeah and it's um it's fabulous as
far as people sharing content from years
past
here's what I'll say if you're gonna
share content from years past give me
something new like Kylie to this whole
thing which she was like you might not
know like this dress actually didn't
have a zipper but I busted out of it and
we added a zipper on my way out like
little fun facts like that live for Katy
Perry showing us the outfit she was
already planning on wearing but like
obviously they never finished it would
have like a baby bump thing on it very
cool if you're gonna show me something
new but just don't close to old pictures
of you like that's just bragging
I completely agree like there are some
interesting tidbits I know Derek
Blasberg has been posting like series of
photos of him like selfies with celebs
that are just interesting groups of
people of photos that I haven't seen
before and that's the sort of thing that
I'm interested in but like to see your
your measly red carpet look again um I'm
all set did they ever um announce what
the theme would have been this year yeah
it was I mean I'm not gonna get it off
the top of my head but it was the theme
of the met um something big something
berry V yeah like it was okay um okay
well happy for Elon and Grimes this next
story is also the big story of the day
Scott Disick checks into then out of
rehab rehab to work on past traumas
Scott Disick checked himself into rehab
in April though he's already headed home
quote in an effort to finally come to
term
and deal with the pain that Scott has
been silently suffering for many years
due to the southern death of his mother
followed by the death of his father
three months later Scott made the
decision to check himself into a rehab
facility last week to work on his past
traumas his attorney Marty singer told
page six on Monday evening quote he did
not check in for any alcohol or cocaine
abuse shockingly as a result of the
HIPAA violation of the facility and his
violation of privacy he has checked
himself out and is immediately returning
home we are alarmed by this extreme
invasion of privacy and plan to take
immediate legal action so he checked
into the rehab there was uh someone
leaked that he was there and now he's
coming home the way that this was
reported was so strange because it was
reported widely yesterday that he
checked into rehab yesterday for
substance abuse and then late last night
his lawyer reached out to someone and
said he wasn't there for substance abuse
he actually already left because he was
doing like a group therapy in a zoom
session and someone screenshotted it
that is so [ __ ] up
so [ __ ] up I mean it's it's it's just
awful I mean I haven't seen the zoom
screenshot like circulated maybe I don't
know if it was distributed but it was
the photo was taken when Judah was taken
sent to a news outlet and now keep the
news outlet confirmation to report on
the fact that he was in rehab yeah this
is really [ __ ] up and I'm sure that
this facility is no longer going to be a
do business because they're gonna sue
the hell out of him
what facility was it and I don't know if
I said it um but I just feel bad for
Scott like especially if he was there
for grief and like we literally just saw
all this happened this week on
Kardashian's like I just I really feel
for him like where's Sofia me too I feel
like she's there I feel like she's being
supportive as much as she possibly can
be but this is a journey he has to be on
on his own you know and he just started
to do that and like someone [ __ ]
ruined it for him and that's atrocious
yeah and and if he was struggling with
grief I'm sure like quarantining even if
he was with with Sophia but just like
that sense of like isolation and being
alone did not help yeah definitely I
really feel for him I love him so much
and um I hope that he's able to find the
solace that he needs
me too I love him so much on this week's
episode when his leg out of town uncle
came and they were on the phone at first
he was like I like your new TV show flip
it like Jessica that was so cute and so
funny
his uncle snitch s his uncle's niece
Jess okay next up Kristin Cavallari and
Jay Cutler reach a joint custody and
property agreement this is so
interesting their divorce has just been
like fast-tracked in the queue so many
different updates we haven't talked
about it recently but it seems like they
are finally on the same page Kristin
Cavallari and Jay Cutler reached
agreements on the two contentious points
of their divorce their children and
their money
according to docs obtained by page six
Kristin and Jay agreed that Kristin can
use their marital funds to purchase a
new home their three children will stay
at the current home until Kristen moves
into the new property the kids will
remain in the house while Kristen and
Jay will switch off who stays with them
once she settles into her new home
Kristin previously claimed that Jay was
blocking her from buying a new house um
this is very Gina Gershon hider of them
and I like this idea that like I guess
now divorce couples are doing where the
kids say in the house and the parents
which as opposed to the kids going back
and forth from different houses I guess
that's kind of nice like if you can live
that life where you have like multiple
homes and you can be in but I don't know
it just seems like you would want to
like have roots with your kids in the
same house I got I don't know if I would
do it it's simply like an interesting
new method that people are doing um
and it's definitely one that I feel
would be a lot easier if you're rich
yeah I don't know if I would do it but
it's an interesting new method and it's
interesting they also need to be three
houses right one for creating one for
and one for the kids yet they already
have two houses so it's literally just
like getting one more I don't know
what's gonna happen with those other two
houses but they're so like such nice
houses and they need houses so why not
just go back to your old houses they
also agreed to be joint primary
residential parents and each will spend
one hundred and eighty two point five
days with the children each year um
the Jay will have the kids every other
Friday after school until the following
Friday after school it's like very down
to every phone call like it's
very court-approved that's actually Oh
crazy I feel like in most situations
like the mom just gets mostly full
custody and then they do like weekends
or whatever every other week this is so
interesting
your mom with like three young kids like
fabulous for sure also Jay doesn't work
and if you see on the show like
Kristin's always the one who's out and
about so I think for Kristin to have
primary custody and to have the kids
whereas Jay like actually has nothing on
his plate it also like doesn't really
make sense yeah that's true
okay well this sounds like it would work
for them this is great
yeah I hope it's working for them I hope
they're getting to that amicable place
that we assumed that they were gonna be
in but unclear if they're going there
there yeah I think the place that we you
know falsely assumed that they were
going to be at I don't know I'm just
optimistic and that's not your fault
okay cuz it's too sad otherwise I know
they were just really that like
instagrammy
like such a cute couple they were
together for so long like that's always
the ones that shake you like the ones
that you just forgot like we're even
married yeah yeah okay next story this
one's for you Nicolas Cage is playing is
it the UM the story that's sponsored by
look what I've a liquid IV is an easy
healthy solution for dehydration one
stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you faster and more
efficiently than water alone each
serving provides as much hydration as
two to three bottles of water plus
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12 if you're
dehydrated try liquid ID it's the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated and low key really helps the
hangover when you need it to proper
hydration is crucial for your immune
system and can boost your immunity more
vitamin C then and then an orange and it
has as much potassium as banana it's
packed with vitamins b3 b5 b6 and b12
vitamins known to help your body defend
against infections one thing we love
most about liquid IV is that they're on
a mission to change the world they're
donating 2.3 million servings in
response to coded 19 products are being
donated to hospitals first responders
food banks veterans and active military
believe it or not dehydration occurs
daily and three out of four people I
totally believe that which leads to
headaches dizziness brain
muscle fatigue muscle cramps dry skin
and more to stay hydrated with a lot
alone you'd have to drink eight full
eight ounce glasses of water today and I
just I know I have a lot of time in
quarantine but I do not have enough time
you drink 8 ounces like it just takes
forever I don't have the time like what
I'd be is so fabulous aside from being
helpful with a hangover I get migraines
like on the daily most of the time
attributed to the fact that I don't
drink enough water and like what I be
really really helps with that thankfully
there's like what I be the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated liquid IV
is available nationwide at Target Whole
Foods in Costco or you can get 25% off
when you go to liquid IV dot-com and use
the code toast at checkout that's 25%
off anything you order when you use
promo code toast at liquid I b.com get
better hydration today at liquid I be
calm using the promo code toast you can
also find them nationwide at Target
Whole Foods and Costco love it I love
like what IV it's definitely the thing
that you need to drink in the queue stay
hydrated um okay let's say internet
story I thought I had something else to
say but I forgot Nicholas Cage is gonna
be playing the Tiger Kings Joe exotic in
the scripted series from American
vandals showrunner Nicolas Cage is said
to star in a scripted series centered on
Joe exotics the subject of the Netflix
docu-series Tiger King variety has
learned exclusively the 8 episode series
is being produced by imagine television
studios and CBS television studios it
will be taken to market in the coming
days it is based on the Texas Monthly
article Joe exotic a dark journey into
the world of a man gone wild I mean this
sounds like a good casting but is it
just me or are there like 10 projects in
the air in Hollywood about Tiger King
like which I heard one about Kate
McKinnon like which one is this maybe
this is the Kate McKinnon one I don't
know I'm looking at this picture and
they really look like Hollywood always
does this where they get like a decent
story and then they make like five of
the same sort of picture about it um I
didn't you know I didn't watch the
series but you know what this is kind of
reminding me of which I just realized
remember the Anna del V story of course
so like the the article came out and it
was so fascinating was such a crazy
story and then there was like a few
other articles like following up with
more information I recently
in American greed episode about an Adele
D and I couldn't finish it because it
was like at first the story is
interesting but like once you hear it
like two or three times it's like
actually pretty boring it's looser and
looser crime and it's just like how do
you get yourself into this situation and
so um I know that there's like a Syria
there's AI pretty sure like Shonda
Rhimes was working on a series about
Burnett but it's like by the time that
comes out it's just like there's not
that much story there to be told over
and over again yeah well I find that
like these crazy stories get told over
and over again in like documentary form
American greed like I do think watching
it in a scripted show will be a
different experience like I will watch
the an Adele B thing even though it's
been too long like that thing happened
like two years ago I think we were doing
the breath when it happened like it's so
long ago yeah I I just like there's like
it's an interesting story in the moment
but like to keep regurgitating it over
and over again you get to the point
where it's like okay this girl's like
not that interesting she's really
strange and the people that she swindled
like come on you're really gonna give
this girl thousands of dollars like at a
certain point it's like you it's just
not that interesting yeah I think what's
with an Adele V because it was just an
article we never really got to see like
a visual of it played out which i think
is what makes it different than tiger
king like to me tiger king is already so
played out like the documentary was so
long that like i don't really need to
see more but i've actually i want to see
what an Adele v looks like do you know
any mean or like a representation of
what she looked like okay i think if you
like watch the American greed episode
which is pretty much a documentary about
the story like you'll realize that
you're not interested in this woman
whatsoever also one of the her friends
wrote a book called my friend Anna
that's what it was making me think about
this because someone posted about it in
the redheads yesterday I was just like I
don't need to read a whole book about
this either like I got this story from
the article the story it was interesting
but now I'm moving on I don't need to
see it like five other iterations of it
you know it's just so funny that you
brought up an Adele B because I didn't
realize that I followed her on Instagram
and all that stuff went down but she's
in jail I'm like when when she was at
the height of her thing like she had
someone like posting on her Instagram
and she actually recently posted on
Instagram and I want to say over the
weekend
that's so weird ya know it's so creepy
when people post from prison yeah I just
was thinking about that and wanted to
share with the class so ya know it's an
interesting conversation
yeah just like there's a lot of stories
out there go find them um next story
which is um about what we were talking
about yesterday but now we have the full
details of the Twilight new book that is
coming out
Twilight offer reveals new book midnight
sun GMA has an exclusive reveal of the
cover of the new book from Stephenie
Meyer the long-anticipated retelling of
Twilight from Edward Collins point of
view so it's not a prequel it's the same
story from Edwards point of view which
I'm actually sort of into um that's kind
of cool
I guess the movie but the original book
was probably Bella's point of view
because the movie is know and even like
when even in the movie like when we we
see everything from Bella's point to be
like we're in her house and her feelings
and like her talking to her friends like
what was happening at Edwards house when
he first saw Bella at school like what
did he go home and do he didn't come to
school for what was going through his
head and to me he's such a more
interesting character than Bella was
like Bella was just so quiet and like
mean to her dad
but Edward had this like full life up in
that mansion and on a hill so I think
this sounds fabulous I'm worried though
that they'll adapt it into a movie and
there's no way we're gonna get Robert
Pattinson to play that role so we'll
have to get Robert Pattinson and that
makes me sad yeah that does make me sad
I hope that it's not a dachshund I mean
I hope that it is but also Twila is just
so perfect like leave it me Twilight is
so perfect like I could watch that the
one Breaking Dawn Part one where they
get married on their honeymoon the end
of the movie where she like kind of dies
like that's not my favorite but that
first half of the movie to me it's like
the most perfect love story of our
generation like that wedding that dress
that the night that they had sex for the
first time like all of that it's like
what romance is like his speech at the
wedding you know no amount of time will
be long enough let's start with forever
like true romance like I I think that
like I could watch that first half of
Breaking Dawn and be the happiest woman
alive forever it's so it's so true
music from all the movies is so good and
like it's so tailored to the movies but
also it's like captures the pop culture
and I'm not even talking about a
thousand years christina perri which is
the best song of all time like true
which we got in some Twilight and we
gotta brought to fly like - right right
like but everything else just the
soundtracks like you listen to the
soundtrack and you feel like you're in
the movie that is just so well done
we're so obsessed with Twilight growing
up like we just loved it so much and I
listened to that soundtrack like and
there's just so many songs like I've
never heard outside of Twilight but if I
if someone just played it right now I'd
be like this is the song controlling I'm
like Bella's making up yeah like I could
actually lodge a whole podcast about I
love it so much and I rewatched recently
because you didn't like you totally
inspired me and it was one of like it
was I wish I almost didn't do it so that
I could do it right now and like have it
all come back to me but like what and I
watched it with Ben and him he liked it
I know we spoke about this yesterday but
part of me wishes I didn't watch it with
him because I spoke about last week I
like whenever I'm watching something um
if it's like emotional or sad like Ben
always looks at me and like makes fun of
me and I have these very emotional
reactions to Twilight and I found myself
like holding it in because I knew Ben
was gonna make fun of me so maybe I'll
do it again without Ben because he was
just like making me self-conscious yeah
also like if you trust my take on things
you should do it with High School
Musical it's such a treat it's such a
treat yes yes yes yes because like Zak
and Vanessa are that love story they're
so in love with each other
alright you know what I'll think about
it I'll think about it I've been wanting
to UM to do something like that like
dive into a franchise I think that
that's the one for you I really do
yesterday I got like the itch to like
start Glee again but I don't think that
I can because I do this thing where I
starkly and I I'm so head over heels for
the first five seasons and no matter
what I say every time I'm gonna finish
it I'm gonna finish it I never finish it
you know that I'm the biggest Glee fan
and I've never finished Glee it's cuz
you don't want it to be over no I do
it's just like it gets so bad like after
finding they're like living in New York
and Santana becomes the understudy in um
Fanny Brice like it's just so
unrealistic um and I just get frustrated
and I always face out and I start again
I'm like this
is the time I'm gonna finish clay no
never finish it yeah I feel that
well I there's actually some good stuff
to watch I need to watch Holly what I'm
saving it and you watch season four of
money heist I'm saving that too I just
need to have like some things I might
never watch these things just so that
I'm always having something to look
forward to that's nice because once
you've actually watched everything on
planet Earth I don't think there's a
lesser feeling in the world yeah I
totally agree with that um okay well
those were the five stories very
interesting stuff um we have more to
talk about tbh recap but that part of
the show is brought to you by legacy box
the super simple mail and service to
have all your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive DVD
or the cloud Mother's Day is fast
approaching what are you getting for
your mom what about the gift of memories
this is such a fabulous product we used
to literally watch so many of our home
videos growing up you had to get like a
VCR adapter an adapter DVD DVD blu-ray
like so many things you would end up
like breaking your cassette but legacy
box is like the most perfect company
they send you a box you throw all you
can digitize pictures videos throw it
all in a box slap the label on and they
get it back to you they can send it in a
thumb drive it's really really fabulous
it is the perfect way for you to easily
unaffordable digitally preserve your
past from start to finish it's so easy
you pack it and send it their team
digitize it digitize does everything by
hand you get it back and enjoy you can
get perfectly preserved digital copies
on thumb drives DVD or on the cloud with
ready to watch share and enjoy plus they
keep you up to date with regular emails
throughout the process
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home videos photos and has
helped over 750,000 families digitally
preserve their past rediscover your
glory days by digitizing these
irreplaceable heirlooms with legacy box
when the favorite kid award this
Mother's Day and give mom a president
she'll never forget for a limited time
legacy box is running at 50% off the
mother's day special order your legacy
box today and take advantage of this
incredible offer this is one of the best
discounts they've ever offered
legacy box is perfect for you or for
someone you love go to legacy box.com
slash toast and say 50% off wallace
supplies last
legacy box is the best thing like
personally but it's also the best gift
to give anybody because it's so
thoughtful and it's gonna mean some
them cuz everybody has a closet full of
videotapes and things they don't know
what to do is and I actually want to
watch
so legacy box the best sign on be a good
gift giver do you remember like when we
used to scrapbook our photos like from
bar mitzvahs and stuff yeah that was fun
I love scrapbooking that's actually a
great hobby to take up during quarantine
it is I've been thinking about getting
back into knitting you know I took up
knitting
um Spring Break of junior year remember
when we had a trip planned to Puerto
Rico and the day before we left we
realized mom didn't have a passport yeah
come here Iike what did I say
Puerto Rico Costa Rica so we stayed home
all of Spring Break and that was
actually the same the same the same day
I learned how to knit was the same day
Margo Charlotte for the first time Wow
I'll never forget that she and I were
watching TV we were so bored and she
went to the kitchen you know she always
eats weird things like even as a kid so
she made this weird concoction of sliced
up pickles and like old tuna fish she
brought it into the bedroom and she
literally was for five minutes and I'll
never forget Claudia oh my god I think I
just sharted and she ran to the bathroom
it was the funniest experience ever and
I also I remember not being able to help
because I was in the middle of knitting
and that's my Spring Break of junior
year wow that's niche well it's her
birthday tomorrow so everyone makes sure
to send her some birthday love so the
Queen Tyra
yeah for sure like you have to like you
know make some sort of flipagram or
collage for her like yeah about like the
digital present than the physical
present yeah I need to work on like my
post for her do you have something ready
um no of course not I'm gonna go back
into the archives maybe I'd like a
hilarious video of her when we were on
tour like I have become this person who
doesn't take pictures like I was trying
to Instagram for both your husband and
Olivia's husband and I couldn't find
anything like I don't take pictures yeah
well now after the queue will will
change that yeah well my time hop today
has been giving me like Marco's
birthdays of years past when she had a
great Roman themed 21st birthday party
like I'm just so jealous of the person I
used to be
I used to go to so many fun parties yeah
we did well that's just you know what I
watched I forgot to tell everyone I
watched having to be dangerous lies on
Netflix with kami Mendes um I heard not
great things about him
here's the thing maybe the movies not
good but I just loved watching her I
think she's an amazing actress and so I
enjoyed the movie cuz I enjoyed her like
I enjoyed my time with movie I would
recommend it to someone it was like the
perfect fun fair um
she's so great yeah I really like her
um I actually saw something so funny
about Riverdale on tick tock they were
like what has happened to Riverdale and
I haven't watched it in a few years but
it was a scene of Jughead and Betty like
fighting about how jugheads just like
her dorm room boyfriend and they like
start singing a song oh this is probably
from the musical episode but I haven't
watched out yet do they do only one
episode with music or they sing now all
the time they do one musical episode a
season and it's because the Riverdale
high does a musical like it and they all
participate so the whole episode is just
a musical it's actually really cute I
can't believe how obsessed with
Riverdale like we and I used to be and
now I don't even watch it like we
launched a [ __ ] after show after Dale
I love her and I'll still I think I have
a little like PTSD from doing after Dale
which is why I no longer um watch
Riverdale not that we had a bad
experience like we had fun but it was so
like it was so much work and nobody
watch so much pressure we used to have
to get there like watch the whole
episode in like this corporate room and
like the pitch-black dark or it was so
bright and everyone was talking and
yelling at each other and then we had to
do an after-show like about an epic
about a show that it's not how much to
talk about like it was just used to have
to get like full glam like the day would
like start like we had to start
preparing for it like 4 o'clock and me
wouldn't be done until like 10:30 and it
was all for like a TV show that we just
wanted to enjoy ya know that's what it
was it made us stop enjoying it but with
that first season it was like a cultural
reset and I think we thought it would
continue out and it's still a popular
show but it's not like nearly as big of
a deal or as popular as it was seasons 1
& 2 I think that it is you just don't
watch it yeah I just assume if I'm not
watching it's not popular
yeah but I'm watching it
still great look like the quality of the
show is great and I just like to watch
them all together because I can't deal
with all the mystery there's so much
mystery that's how I feel about dynasty
even though I'm like now 14 episodes
behind I'm jealous of you I'm like four
episodes behind now I'm starting to
batch them because they are a little
stupid when you watch them just one-off
the problem with that is like sometimes
you get to a point where you're so
behind like so many episodes that you
just stop watching and that's exactly
what happened to me with Nashville I
watched it and then I stopped a few
episodes and I just never caught up and
honestly I like wish that I hadn't
gotten so far behind because I never
could really pick it up again it was too
much responsibility but why don't you
just binge it now like you would binge
or any other show natural is so good if
you guys haven't watch it and you're
like into steamy fun like TV shows that
is the best show to watch or or if
you're a Lennon Stella fan that's really
where she got her start posting YouTube
the whole thing is so good Connie
Britton Deacon Claybourne who you know
now is Ward Cameron from OBX
um hayden Panettiere it's so good it's
so good her personal life she has like a
lot going on I love her ever since
raising Helen one of the best movies you
guys should definitely watch national if
you have it I actually I finished it um
probably last year like I watched the
last few episodes together and it's just
they really buttoned it up nicely oh
that's nice I like that I could take
that scarlet she was so annoying yeah
she's really annoying she was still
annoying towards the end and I think she
became like a more main character like I
seasons went on right yeah there was
there's definitely a lull there are some
dips but it's a strong show ever any
like soapy show like that has like
random characters and storylines that
you're like what the hell is going on
but overall like it turned out nicely
yeah no that's Desperate Housewives take
member Edie's husband Dave like that was
such a way your time yeah oh my god I
missed I won watch Desperate Housewives
but I can't even lie like I need to I
don't even think I have the time now ya
know I have so much time but no time no
like because then I would just be legit
watching TV all day and like it is a
full-time job to stay out of bed until
like 6 o'clock
yeah that's what I'm gonna try and do
today I'll figure it out
okay well I think that's all she wrote I
don't know did you try anything else I
didn't see anything no I spoke to her
and she said I'm done right okay well
then that's that thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found set
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
already owe cashbox all the places where
ever you listen to podcast find us the
morning trusting a five-star review
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are we love you guys so much
we'll see you tomorrow for home day bye